Acheter du lait à l'épicerie,
c'est un geste qui peut sembler
banal. Mais en hiver, quand
le temps est mauvais, derrière
chaque litre de lait se cache
un parcours parfois épique.
(bruit du vent qui souffle)
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narratrice): Un matin d'hiver
à la Ferme Bruneau et fils,
de Saint-Henri, près de Lévis.
Le mauvais temps s'en vient.
- Il vente pas mal. On a des
champs, on a des beaux champs,
on a des grands champs,
mais le vent vient de loin. Ça
fait que c'est des places qu'il
vente quand même beaucoup, là.
(meuglement)
- Les vaches ne connaissent pas
les saisons. Elles se présentent
au robot et donnent leur lait :
35 litres par jour chacune.
C'est ainsi.
- Tempête, pas tempête.
Journée fériée ou pas journée
fériée, c'est 24 heures sur 24,
7 jours sur 7 que les robots
fonctionnent.
♪ ♪ ♪
À la minute qu'il part
du réservoir du robot ici,
il est acheminé par une conduite
en stainless jusque dans
la laiterie. Puis après ça,
automatiquement, il est tombé
dans le réservoir pour être
refroidi le plus rapidement
possible à 4° C pour la
conservation, jusqu'à temps
que la vanne de lait vienne
ramasser le lait.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le lait cru est collecté
aux deux jours, pas plus.
Encore ce matin au Québec,
305 camions sont sur les routes;
un parcours de 28 millions
de kilomètres par année.
À la Ferme Bruneau, le lait
est transporté par Prolait. Sur
le territoire de l'entreprise,
les hommes ramassent un million
de litres par jour.
Le répartiteur
les suit à la trace.
- S'il y a quelque chose,
rappelle-moi puis on va regarder
ça ensemble. Merci! Salut.
- Environnement Canada
publie un avertissement
de tempête hivernale.
- Juste aujourd'hui, on le voit,
à Montmagny, ils viennent
de fermer les écoles
cet après-midi.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Lévis, Montmagny, Bellechasse;
nous sommes dans la région
la plus venteuse du Québec.
L'effet entonnoir créé par
le rétrécissement du fleuve à
Québec accélère les vents du
nord-est. À l'approche de la
dépression venant de l'ouest,
le mauvais temps s'installe.
Si la neige est fraîche et
les bancs de neige très hauts,
la visibilité est réduite.
Février et mars sont les pires
mois pour le transport du lait.
- Disons que ça te prend des
bons chauffeurs pour ramasser
le lait dans ces secteurs-là.
- Mais le ministère des
Transports réagit vite :
dès que les personnes sont
en danger, les routes ferment.
- Aussitôt que la route 20,
la 132, les rangs de travers,
quand on parle dans la région
de Bellechasse, la route 279,
277, la 281, quand ça, ça ferme,
c'est sûr qu'on peut pas se
rendre à la ferme pour ramasser
le lait.
- Si, après deux jours, le lait
n'est pas ramassé, le producteur
doit le détruire, comme ça
arrive une ou deux fois
par hiver chez Steve Bruneau.
- On n'aura pas le choix
d'ouvrir la valve du réservoir
puis jeter notre lait dans
la fosse à fumier. Relaver tous
nos équipements pour partir en
neuf avec des bassins propres.
- Une réserve collective des
producteurs va compenser Steve.
Mais à tous coups, c'est
quand même la déception.
- Ça nous fait mal au coeur
parce que c'est vraiment notre
passion qu'on est obligé de
jeter, parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de l'envoyer à cause
de la température.
- Le lait est périssable.
L'entreposage est limité.
Retarder ou annuler une
livraison bouleverse tout
le circuit de collecte, de
livraison et de transformation.
- Il y a personne dans
l'industrie qui a intérêt
à ce qu'on dispose du lait
si c'est évitable. Et donc,
l'ensemble des maillons
de la chaîne va prendre
des dispositions pour qu'on
l'évite le plus possible.
- Depuis cinq ans, le volume
de lait éliminé varie de
500 000 litres à un 1,2 million
de litres de lait par année.
- C'est sûr aussi que des fois,
les quantités peuvent sembler
importantes. Il faut être
conscient qu'on produit
65 millions de litres de
lait par semaine en moyenne.
Ça reste que les producteurs
produisent du lait pour nourrir
les gens. C'est leur souhait
que le lait serve à fabriquer
des produits laitiers.
Alors, de produire du lait qui
servira pas et qui sera disposé,
c'est jamais une situation
heureuse pour un producteur.
- D'année en année, c'est
un petit peu plus... disons que
les routes, elles ferment plus
tôt. Disons que le ministère
des Transports, dans le fond,
ils prennent pas de chance.
Ça va être impossible de
le ramasser aujourd'hui...
- Pour Jean Cadorette, le pire
épisode remonte à mars 2008,
où certains producteurs ont dû
jeter le lait deux fois la même
semaine.
- J'ai même un chauffeur qui est
resté pris dans un rang cette
journée-là. Et il est resté
19 heures dans son camion parce
que la municipalité pouvait pas
envoyer de machinerie, il y
avait pas de machinerie assez...
Il faisait pas beau.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour aujourd'hui, Steve
n'est pas inquiet. La route
peut fermer, le réservoir est
à moitié plein. Et les vaches
font leur lait, tranquilles.
- Qu'il fasse beau ou qu'il
fasse pas beau, t'as pas le
choix : il faut que tu les
nourrisses, il faut que
tu les traies. Puis nous, la
roue continue, dépendamment de
la météo; on n'a pas le choix.